[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue nous avons le plaisir ce soir
pour commenter l'actualité la plus
immédiate d'accueillir deux invités
bonsoir guillaume bigot vous êtes
politologue chroniqueur sur la chaîne
ses news votre dernier livre la pop une
phobie le gouvernement de l'élite par
l'élite et pour l'élite a été publié aux
éditions plon
et puis j smadja et là aussi bon soir
gilles vous êtes le directeur de cabinet
du maire de nanterre et vous avez été
journaliste à l'humanité
c'était il ya quelques années déjà
évidemment nous commençons par traité
l'actualité la plus forte est aussi la
plus dramatique de cette journée ce
matin à 10h15 une policière municipale a
été agressé à coups de couteau à la
chapelle-sur-erdre c'est une commune au
nord de nantes
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin s'est rendu sur place cet après
midi et voici le point qu'il a fait il y
à quelques minutes sur cette agression
police municipale de la commune et a
agressé sauvagement au couteau une
policière municipale qui heureusement
manifestement survivra à ses blessures
l'individu a pris la fuite qui a été
retrouvé et qui a voulu manifestement
sans prendre de nouveau aux gendarmes
puisqu'il a tiré avec la larme qui
n'aurait manifestement pris à la
policière municipale aidé a été
neutralisée et cet auteur est décédé
alors ce que l'on sait du suspect dont
qui a été est décédé à la suite son
interpellation par la gendarmerie c'est
qu'il a une quarantaine d'années il
s'appelle ndiaga dieye et il est de
nationalité française et il était fiché
pour radicalisation on le savait adeptes
d'un islam radical
il a été déjà condamné dans le passé
pour des délits de droit commun et il
était sorti de prison en mars dernier
une actualité de ce type ça évidemment
des répercussions politiques
voici par exemple une réaction celle de
laurent wauquiez qui se demandent
comment est ce que on peut être ainsi
avoir le profil d'une personne
dangereuse et se retrouver dans la
nature entre guillemets précisons que le
suspect était également connu pour
troubles psychiatriques
guillaume bigot est ce qu'il ya une
dimension de responsabilité de l'état
dans cette affaire alors il faut parler
prudemment bien sûr parce qu'on n'en
connaît pas encore tous les détails on
va dire que on savait que cet homme
était radicaliser qu'il était adepte
d'un islam intégral fallait-il pour
autant le mettre hors d'état de nuire
entre guillemets certains ont parlé dans
des affaires précédentes de la nécessité
de d'internement préventif qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
ça c'est une question très très aiguë
règles très complexe la responsabilité
de l'état est de toute façon évidemment
13 engagés en ce qui concerne les le
manque de places de prison la saturation
des places de prison
le garde des sceaux s'est exprimé
récemment et et il ya sans cesse on a
vraiment cette impression de de
reprendre tourner en boucle prononcé les
mêmes mots et maux ts pour les mêmes
mots et mahut x et il ya un effet
vraiment de répétition donc la
responsabilité de l'état oui sur disons
le le manque de places en prison
le manque de place aussi dans les
structures psychiatriques on va voir si
cet homme était relève vraiment de la
psychiatrie mais surtout ces brèves ou
poser la bonne question
il y a quelque chose là qui est qui pour
nous très complexe dans une démocratie
dans un état de moi certes que faire de
gens qui sont déterminés absolument
déterminé par idéologie erreur c'est son
cas à lui il était un élément
psychiatrique je répète mais de toute
façon on sait qu'il y en a des milliers
qui sont absolument déterminé à tout
mettre en oeuvre pour nous abattre et
que ça ne relève pas nécessairement la
psychiatrie et on est dans quelque chose
il n'ya pas nécessairement de passage à
l'acte ou alors il y a eu une peine qui
a été appliquée en partie ou totalement
mais en fait le droit est épuisé ça pose
un véritable problème le pro
me supplémentaires c'est la contagiosité
extrême que favorise le milieu carcéral
puisque manifestement là cet homme il
s'est radicalisé en prison et pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas de solution
et je crois que il faut se retourner sur
le passé
vous savez le bagne à une triste mémoire
en france parce que le bagne c'était
cayenne cayenne c'était des conditions
absolument épouvantable mais disons un
système d'éloignement de la métropole ça
a été aussi la nouvelle calédonie et la
nouvelle calédonie n'a pas du tout donné
les mêmes résultats des guyanes or ce
n'est pas non plus un bail mais c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut inventer à une
situation nouvelle je pense qu'il faut
inventer une solution nouvelle sans
sacrifier notre état de droit bien sûr
mais en mettons qu'ils ont tort vraiment
hors d'état de nuire des gens qui sont
déterminés et qu'ils vont recommencer
c'est une certitude
moi je crois surtout que je crois
surtout que l'âme ce drame pose pose le
problème de la capacité des services de
sécurité et de renseignement de l'état à
faire face à une nouvelle forme de ce
type d'acte je ne qualifie pas encore
l'acte de terroristes d'abord parce que
le parquet antiterroriste à l'heure
qu'il est ne s'est pas encore saisi de
la faire et parce que visiblement les
éléments sur sur la manière dont les
faits se sont déroulés manque pour
pouvoir apporter cette qualification
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'un individu fiché est connu comme
étant un radicalisées a voulu assassiner
une policière municipale ça ce sont les
faits et donc ça pose le problème
ça veut dire qu'il ya une une réelle
évolution on n'est plus dans charlie on
n'est plus dans l'attentât de l'hyper
cacher on n'est plus dans les commandos
du bataclan on est dans autre chose on
est la plupart du temps dans des actes
individuels par des personnes qui ont
été repérés la plupart du temps et
notamment qui ont été repérés en prison
par un système de renseignement que dont
on ne parle pas assez
qu'est le système de renseignement
pénitentiaire à l'intérieur à
l'intérieur des prisons qui procèdent
souvent par infiltration par et la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est
avons-nous aujourd'hui construisons nous
une réponse adaptée à cette situation
nouvelle
mettons nous en place les moyens qui
permettent réellement de suivre ces
individus quel est l'intérêt de ficher
cette personne s'il ne se passe rien
derrière méthode
la solution il y en a pas 36 non c'est
une forme d'internement administratif
cément ce qui est contraire à priori à
nos règles ont droit au versement une
fois ci on a rien de concret à reprocher
à quelqu'un dans le fait qu'il soit
radicaliser n'est pas suffisant pour le
absolument absolument l'état de droit
doit continuer de prix mais dans tous
les cas toutes les situations il y à
d'autres formes de surveillance possible
il y à des alternatives à l'enfermement
à la prison il yad'autres surveillance
possible il ya des surveillances voilà
je sais qu'un certain nombre de pays par
exemple à quoi un bracelet électronique
exemple par exemple par exemple des
obligations de deux pointages des
obligations par exemple d éloignement de
réserver il y a des réponses à
construire qui permettent de valider le
fait qu'on estime qu'un individu il est
il est potentiellement dangereux ou
encore ou alors il faut arrêter enfin à
quoi ça sert d'avoir tout ce fichage si
on ne s'en sert pas pour la sécurité oui
on s'en sert d joue énormément crime
d'amour heureusement beaucoup de gens
vont vous dire qu'en l'occurrence là
c'est un échec
c'est un échec parce que parce qu'un
individu qui est extrait pied quand même
présumé très dangereux il a été condamné
pour des faits de violence 2 il a été
d'ailleurs il a fait la totalité de sa
peine
exactement il n'a pas bénéficié de
remises de peine c'est un français qui
est né en france
donc voyez tous les toutes les
rodomontades sur le fait les étrangers
tout ça en l'occurrence là c'est
totalement ce n'est pas du tout
pertinent on est on est face à autre
chose et dollars ce qu'on peut dire
quand même que par son patronyme il
semble être issus de l'immigration
oui mais depuis combien de générations
je les ignore voilà donc c'est un
français qui est né en france et qui
avaient
voilà mais bon pour moi la principale
question que pose à nouveau ce drame
après d'autres c'est qu'elles quel type
de sécurité en mai en place par rapport
à ces individus qui sont considérés
comme dangereux et qui ont fait l'objet
d'une surveillance partie des questions
très importantes parce que là on a des
outils classiques on a des outils
classiques de surveillance d box a posé
question de moyens très importants il ya
mille personnes qui vont sortir de
l'incarcération
après avoir purgé leur peine pour des
motifs d'associations années des actes
terroristes et une personne s'est dit
personne du renseignement pour
surveiller une personne voilà les ordre
d'idée or il s'agit pas de déclencher
une panique mais on les spécialistes
disent qu'on est très au delà de la
saturation
on ne peut pas surveiller on n'a pas
suffisamment de gens pour surveiller
efficacement tous les gens et c'est
d'autant plus vrai que les surveiller
c'était un mur
disons un modus opéra du classique
lorsqu'il ya des réseaux la surveillance
là est intéressante parce qu'on ne
ferait pas pour surveiller on surveille
pour démanteler les réseaux
mais lorsque vous avez tout à fait
raison votre argument est pertinent
lorsqu'à passage à l'acte individuel
ces mécanismes de surveillance ne sont
plus vraiment efficace deuxièmement même
si vous mettez de race électronique
pouvez pas empêcher le passage à l'acte
à l'instant d'envoyer ça pose un
problème redoutable par ailleurs les
techniques qu'on avait on sait bercer
d'illusions en pensant qu'on allait
retourner ces gens avec des techniques
de déradicalisation etc
ça ne fonctionne pas donc en réalité je
pense qu'il ya quelque chose qui est
nouveau et 7,7 irruption du nouveau
oblige nos états de droit nous
démocratie sans se renier à inventer des
solutions nouvelles et kerguelen voyez
ça pourrait être peuplée il ya de l'eau
dans les cars ghalem c'est pas des
conditions évidemment idéal m'enfin ça
allait à peu près la même latitude que
les falklands
on pourrait envoyer ces gens là bas par
exemple du moins tant qu'ils n'ont pas
renoncé à leur idéologie ça fait hurler
ou ça fait bondir mais quelle auquel
meilleure solution que de leurs
principes ça vous choque ce genre de
hulu 7 ce genre de solution a été mise
en oeuvre ou en nouvelle calédonie en
nouvelle zélande c'est comme ça que ces
pays se son peuple et je vous signale
c'est comme ça non me veut dire là
aujourd'hui qu'elle est oui mais c'est
un vrai les gens qui avaient décidé d'en
finir mais aujourd'hui la démocratie au
monde qui préconise ce type de solution
les états unis avec guantanamo ne pas
connais pas ces pays record que non mais
mais d'ailleurs tellement nuls ats-unis
avec guantanamo mais on n'a pas
forcément donné les résultats
la logique c'est notre société ils
veulent faire une contre société et on
ne peut pas évidemment et même les
peines au risque de surprendre
je pense que les peines de très très
très longue durée sont parfaitement
inhumaines en réalité 30 ans 40 ans je
vous donne des réactions de nos
internautes celle de gisèle qui nous dit
même si les services de renseignement
sont efficaces tant qu'un radicaliser
n'est pas passée à l'acte il ne peut pas
être appréhendées effectivement c'est le
sujet nos démocraties sont trop faibles
à l'égard des radicaliser et olympe
s'est radicalisée et ne nous n'avons pas
les outils pour nous défendre et puis
gabriel sur youtube
l'état n'a pas échoué sur le plan de la
surveillance des radicaliser il a failli
en naturalisant une masse d'individus
aux valeurs non occidentales la même
s'il est réel il faut préciser que
l'atome était français c'est pas le cas
de tous les
les meurtriers de policiers récents on
se souvient par exemple qu'à rambouillet
en avril dernier
effectivement le l'assassin de la
policière n'étaient pas français
vous pensez guillaume bigot que la
réaction du gouvernement c'est la bonne
ministre de l'intérieur qui se rend sur
place ou est ce qu'il n'ya pas un effet
de répétition qui fait que les français
peuvent se dire mais finalement il ya
une forme d'impuissance là il ya il n'y
a que des mots en face de ces de ses
actes terribles si on peut même sait et
c'est vrai des actes terroristes c'est
vrai en général des faits divers
sordides et donc on peut même se
demander monsieur dharmanand se déplace
le discours qui est d'une certaine façon
un peu des magnétophones sociale c'est
de dire que mais il ne peut pas faire
autrement que se déplacer ne peut pas
faire autrement de multiplier les
déclarations il ne peut pas mais un
moment trop de déclarations tuer les
déclarations je ne sais pas si monsieur
darmanin est en état de rentrer place
beauvau il faut quasiment qui circulent
en permanence dans le pays parce que
tous les jours toutes les 24 heures dont
à l'intérieur d'un intervalle de 24
heures il ya plusieurs faits divers
sordides qui mériterait que le ministre
de l'intérieur et donc voyez il ya
quelque chose qui d'un autre dans notre
sensibilité aussi qui finit par
s'émousser
à un moment on a on s'habitue à ce qui
est c'est la banalité du mal dont
parlait en arabe
je pense qu'il est important que quand
se produit ce type de drame qui touche
un agent du service public
je crois qu'il est très important que
l'état au plus haut niveau
manifeste sa compassion manifeste sa
solidarité manifeste sa détermination
ça ne suffit pas mais ça ne le fit pas
mais il ne faudrait surtout pas qu'on en
arrive imagine l inverse
vous croyez que ce serait accepter l
inverse c'est impensable
ce serait impensable d'imaginer qu'un
tel drame se produise sans que personne
ni à le ministère de l'intérieur il
reste à paris personne ne va exprimer le
soutien de l'état non je pense que c'est
c'est juste c'est normal il faut le
faire c'est tout à fait important et je
pense que le que les français approuvent
ce type d'attitude même si effectivement
on peut ce qui est extrêmement
désarçonnant ce qui est
oui c'est qu'on se sent à l'impression
d'une certaine impuissance et d'une
certaine incapacité à pouvoir prévenir
ce type d'actes qui sont des actes
extrêmement individus alors peut-être
aussi faudrait-il penser à renforcer
quand même les accès à ce type de poste
de police peut-être que peut-être que le
fait d'ouvrir comme ça à la porte et de
pouvoir rentrer peut-être que c'est pas
forcément aujourd'hui c'est plus du tout
adapté enfin voilà donc oui mais en tout
cas moi je soutiens totalement le fait
que l'état soit présent à chaque fois
que c'est nécessaire sur le terrain
l'été at il failli dans la surveillance
des radicaliser c'est une question qu'on
vous pose sur twitter et vous répondez
non à 67%
guillaume bigot cette question est
tellement banal que que on a
l'impression d'avoir déjà posé sans foi
mais un acte comme celui ci dans le
contexte électoral du pays ça a
forcément des conséquences
bien sûr que c'est à dire que là
aujourd'hui le rassemblement national le
ce qui pourrait ce qu'ils peuvent faire
de mieux pour optimiser leur score c'est
ne plus rien dire en réalité c'est
peut-être ce qui est plus difficile
d'ailleurs pour un dirigeant politique
c'est de ne pas s'exprimer
mais là en l'occurrence oui l'actualité
et est une bande annonce pour le
rassemblement national pour répondre
directement à votre question est par
ailleurs la réaction des internautes est
évidemment très saine parce que les
services de renseignement sont
extraordinairement redoutablement
efficace en france extrêmement mobilisés
extrêmement professionnel et il évite
quand même l'essentiel de ce qui
pourrait nous menacer au delà de ça je
pense qu'il faut interroger plusieurs
choses notamment le phénomène de vases
communicants entre parce qu'on est on
part d'une partie d'une part émergée de
l'iceberg
en réalité cet islamisme violent le
passage à l'acte djihadiste est très
très minoritaire en revanche il y à des
phénomènes vase communiquant avec la
propagation d'un autre islamisme qui lui
alors il relève de l'entrisme quand on
veut se rassurer mais il est il a aussi
il est aussi très séduisant pour toute
une partie de la jeunesse de notre pays
et donc il ya finalement un phénomène de
vases communicants et pour l'instant
effectivement on prend les coups sans
pouvoir riposter
on est poussé à la faute c'est une ligne
de crête on sait que c'est extrêmement
dangereux
la solution guantanamo ou de faire
sauter ils ont nos valeurs l'état devra
l'évoquera si c'est exactement ce
qu'attend lausanne
il faut surtout pas le faire mais rester
comme ça dans le dans le coin du ring et
d'encaisser des coups sans pouvoir
riposter
ça ne va pas non plus c'est pour ça que
je pense qu'il faut vraiment inventé
j'aimerais pouvoir être aussi élogieux
que vous sur le travail de nos services
de renseignements sur la doctrine qui
préside au travail de nos services de
renseignement
moi je ne suis pas un spécialiste mais
j'ai lu quand même un certain nombre
d'ouvragés de spécialistes qui par
exemple avait révélé les failles
nombreuses sur le manque de
communication d'informations entre les
différents services le service de
renseignement pénitentiaire a souvent
était mise en cause à cause de ça sur le
fait que les renseignements de personnes
incarcérées qui se radicalise n'était
pas communiquée à d'autres services et
que ça aurait été bien utile de le faire
donc moi je crois qu'il ya quand même là
il ya quand même il ya un souci et il ya
une marge de progression je vais vous
parler au passé je pense à juste titre
parce que je crois que ce problème a été
identifié et que ce sera mérité
régulation même tardivement je crois
existe mieux maintenant entre le
renseignement intérieur et c'est bon on
a un coordinateur national de la lutte
oui c'est non mais c'est un qui est
d'ailleurs la crise y aussi arrêté un
énorme un par un pas en avant très
important
par ailleurs on peut voit là une
solution et je pense qu'il faut mettre
ça dans le débat public comme on dit
suivant l'expression consacrée
c'est peut-être si on ne se paye pas de
mots si nous sommes bel et bien en
guerre de rétablir des tribunaux
militaires
c'est à dire que les tribunaux
militaires sont pas les tribunaux qu'il
fusille c'est pas le sujet de rétablir
la peine de mort en revanche c'est un
circuit judiciaire qui est distinct du
circuit civil qui va traiter des gens
suivant effectivement des règles
exceptionnel et puis il ya eu aussi une
protection des magistrats de l'appareil
judiciaire de l'appareil d'état fin bon
là on arrête de rigoler si vous voulez
des tribunaux qui ont existé en d'autres
temps notamment jusqu'aux années 70
absolument je ne suis pas du tout
certain que ce soit lors que ce soit la
bonne réponse je pense que le droit le
droit que nous avons le droit le droit
civil le droit pénal peut permettre
d'apporter de réponse après c'est la
preuve
oui mais les réponses mais je parle des
réponses en termes de droit je parle pas
moi aussi les conventions européennes
vous savez nous
nos ligues merci je laisse le dernier
mot à zoé qui intervient dans notre
débat pour nous dire ce n'est pas la
question d'avoir ou non les bons outils
il y à un manque de volonté politique
nous passons un autre sujet de cette
émission
l'enseignement des langues régionales il
y avait une proposition de loi qui est
passé à l'assemblée qu'elle ailleurs été
adoptée qui visait à favoriser le la vie
et la transmission de ces langues
régionales le breton le basque et le
conseil constitutionnel en fin de
semaine dernière a censuré une des
dispositions de cette loi en interdisant
ce qu'on appelle l'enseignement immersif
c'est à dire que il ya certaines écoles
qui sont des écoles privées hors contrat
dans lesquelles le l'essentiel de
l'enseignement pouvait être effectué
dans une langue régionale et le conseil
constitutionnel a estimé que cette
mesure était contraire aux principes de
la république selon lequel nous n'avons
qu'une seule langue et c'est le français
ce qui est intéressant c'est que au plus
haut niveau de l'état on semble vouloir
contourner cette décision écouter
l'intervention du premier ministre jean
castex en début de semaine
les langues régionales je le dis devant
votre assemblée sont une chance pour la
république française il n'y a pas
d'opposition entre ces langues
régionales et le français langue de la
république la question de l'enseignement
immersif et il nous appartient
politiquement de tirer toutes les
conséquences de la décision de censure
du conseil constitutionnel
voilà le message a été compris il est
probable qu'ils venaient du plus haut
niveau de l'état puisqu'elles emmanuel
macron lui aussi et est intervenu sur ce
sujet c'était avant-hier sur facebook en
expliquant qu'il l'avait demandé au
gouvernement et au parlement de trouver
les moyens de garantir la transmission
de cette diversité linguistique
gilles smadja qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la position du conseil
constitutionnel est ce que effectivement
c'est dangereux est ce qu'il ya un
risque de séparatisme c'est le mot que
nous avons employé pour parler de ce
sujet avec ces langues régionales et
langues régionales ne sont pas un danger
pour la république
elles sont elles sont une elles sont une
constitutive de la delà de ce qui fait
la france depuis depuis très longtemps
ça fait partie de la diversité de la
richesse culturelle de notre pays
je mets je mets une ligne jaune à ne pas
franchir
c'est que le français doit rester la
langue de l'état du fonctionnement des
services publics la langue qui fait que
nous sommes une communauté de destin qui
fait que nous sommes une nation donc les
langues régionales oui bien sûr ça peut
être tout à fait ça fait partie de notre
patrimoine qu'il connaît les enfants
apprennent à l'école notamment les
langues régionales ça vous choque pas
non ça ne me choque donc qu'ils
apprennent qu'ils apprennent le breton
le corse et le canal en breton ça ne ça
ne me choque pas non revanche ce qui me
choquerait c'est que le français
disparaisse de ces de ces lieux
d'enseignement et d'appréhension parce
qu'encore une fois le français ce n'est
pas une langue parmi d'autres avec ses
langages ionale le français c'est ce qui
fait que nous sommes que là que ce pays
est devenu une nation et un état voilà
donc
moi je pense que la question c'est
jusqu'où on met le jusqu'aux os mais la
limite le curseur voilà l'autre problème
que ça pose qui pour moi est très
sérieux c'est que les écoles
l'enseignement en immersion de certaines
écoles comme diwan et d'autres avec la
loi et calbo d'ailleurs le conseil
constitionnel n'a pas retoqué cette
disposition c'est que ces écoles là avec
cette nouvelle loi peuvent accéder à des
financements publics
au même titre que les écoles privées et
là ça pose un vrai problème parce que là
du coup je moi mon sentiment c'est qu'en
faisant comme ça on va accentuer le
phénomène d'évitement de l'école
publique
on va à nouveau créer des des systèmes
qui font que un certain nombre de gens
vont se tourner vers d'autres réponses
que l'école publique et les communes
vont à nouveau devoir financer autre
chose que de l'enseignement public ça je
trouve que ça pose un problème de fond
guillaume bigot ce qui me semble il ya
deux choses qui me paraissent vraiment
très intéressante dans cette affaire
d'abord je trouve que c'est une un cas
d'école c'est le cas de le dire de cette
dérive politique consistant à prendre
des problèmes folklorique des problèmes
anecdotique des problèmes qui relèvent
de l'ultra minorités et de les mettre
sur le devant de la scène avec souvent
une arrière pensée c'est le cas des
grands débats sociétaux qui est que
finalement c'est cette réplique des
tontons flingueurs touche pas au grisbi
[ __ ]
voilà chers qu'en fait on va prendre
quelque chose a interrogé des principes
articles de la constitution villers
cotterêts et serra et les gens vont se
bouffer le nez en quelque sorte autour
d'enjeux idéologique de principe
et puis finalement on a alors qu'il ya
des enjeux collectifs d enjeu politique
majeur qui intéresse l'intérêt général
et qui ne sont absolument pas traité et
qui disparaissent et ça c'est quand même
fou dans un pays où les banlieues flambe
où on ne sait pas effectivement si la
reprise économique permettra de
redresser le pays demain il ya des
enjeux massif
alors j'entends bien qu'il faut pas
arrêter notre vie démocratique il faut
pas rater l'horloge je comprends bien
mais enfin là c'est quand même très
étonnant qu'elle soit l'écriture
inclusive où les langues locales
on est dans du picrochole 1 on est dans
du microscopique et qui va avoir un
effet de diversion le deuxième argument
c'est que bien sûr
bien sûr c'est une injonction n'est pas
du tout une urgence les langues les
langues régionales ne vont ni connaître
un regain extraordinaire avec cette
mesure ni elles sont en elles sont
menacées simplement de quoi s agit-il il
s'agit d'une injonction de de l'autorité
supérieure de l'échelon supérieur
politique c'est-à-dire de l'union
européenne bruxelles c'est la charte des
langues régionales et les injonctions a
été faite très forte de bruxelles pour
que le lander france obéissent
c'est ça la réalité et alors on va dire
oui mais c'est finalement il n'y a pas
de lien entre les deux sujets je pense
qu'il ya un lien parce que il y a quand
même un sujet majeur qui est la cohésion
nationale qui est ce délitement de
l'autorité qui se manifeste dans plein
de sujets différents sur plein d'aspects
différents
il est peut-être plus profondément lié
au fait que les français ne maîtrisent
plus leur destin et ils ont leur cette
impression de ne plus maîtriser leur
destin et symboliquement c'est très
important
vous êtes le dominant vous êtes m en
tant qu'individu de votre vie en tant
que nous en tant que nation tant que
peuple d'être maîtres de notre destin ou
pas ou alors vous êtes aux ordres et en
réalité ce que signifient ces cônes et
aux oreilles enfin le troisième argument
me semble plus fort encore c'est que
vous avez alors je sais bien que les
sociologues adore dire que le niveau ne
baisse pas que c'est une illusion comme
sur la sécurité
il ya un sentiment d'insécurité n'ya pas
d'insécurité ya un sentiment plus niveau
bas c'est pas vrai bon moi j'ai regardé
dictée de cm2 il ya 30 ans une même
dictée a été passée par des cm2 il y
avait dix fautes en moyenne il ya 19
fautes en moyenne on est passé de 10 à
19 autres l'enseignement du français
s'écroule
la maîtrise du français par les jeunes
français s'écroule et c'est à ce moment
là qu'on envisage je ne suis pas contre
l'enseignement de l'arabe
je ne suis pas contre l'enseignement des
langues régionales mais enfin il faut
d'abord la politique c'est aussi une
question de circonstances et de
s'adapter aux circonstances l'enjeu
central mais semble-t-il est de rétablir
l'enseignement du français
je vous donne la vie de nos internautes
qui kids lors d'un procès très bon un
peu longue mais non mais c'était tout à
fait intéressant qui se débattent
vivement
à la fois sur sur twitter et sur
lefigaro.fr
kriss kross je souhaite surtout que les
jeunes soient parfaitement anglophone
plutôt que excellent en catalan ou en
breton sur never considère au contraire
que les langues régionales sont autant
de patrimoine font partie du patrimoine
comme les monuments ou les plats non
seulement il faut les officialiser à
l'échelon local mais en plus et il faut
renforcer leur enseignement
felip sur youtube est absolument pas
d'accord il dit enseigner des langues
régionales c'est encourager le
séparatisme si jules ferry avait
interdit les patois régionaux à l'école
c'était dans un souci d'unifier la
nation dans une même langue
vous avez parlé au détour d'une phrase
guillaume bigot de l'enseignement de
l'arabe est ce que c'est pas l'une des
raisons même cachet du conseil
constitutionnel qui est de dire
attention si on favorise trop des écoles
en langue régionale ont après ça on
devra aussi favoriser des écoles qui qui
enseigne l'arabe ou qui se montre
prosélyte d'autres d'autres pratiques
mais ce n'est pas grave d'apprendre
l'arabe c'est lorsque l'on maîtrise bien
vraiment bien sûr ça dépend comment
c'est enseigner qui est ce qu'ils
enseignent dans quel cadre avec quel
contenu avec l objectif mais apprendre
apprendre des langues étrangères
quelle qu'elle soit c'est s'ouvrir au
monde c'est pas voilà c'est moi je
trouve ça plutôt bien qu'on favorise
l'enseignement de langue qu'ils soient
pas seulement qui se réduisent pas
seulement à l'anglais qui est devenu
espèce de deux langues d'espéranto
mondiale laquelle auquel tout le monde
devrait se soumettre
donc moi je non je ne pense pas que je
pense pas que c'était c'était ça que
visait le conseil constitutionnel fois
j'en sais rien il ya que moi non plus
c'est une hypothèse
quelques qu'il faudrait nous le dira
mais non moi je crois encore une fois
que d'ailleurs ce qui est très cocasse
dans ce débat je trouve c'est que des
députés qui sont toujours vent debout
contre dès qu'on leur pas vouloir parler
de diversité et de multiculturalisme
ils sont vent debout et là bizarrement
quand comme on leur parle d'enseigner le
catalan le breton
c'est ça pose pas que ça peut flatter
leur électorat à trois semaines des
élections régionales ça ne pose pas mais
c'est parce que c'est pas c'est pas la
même chose entre guillemets sverkos et
ses listes ces langues régionales sont
font plus partie de ce qu'est notre pays
que des langues étrangères comme l'arabe
ben moi je pense que l'arabe fait partie
de notre pays aujourd'hui depuis ça fait
déjà très longtemps je pense que depuis
que pratiquement depuis que la france a
mis un pied en algérie au dîner au
milieu du 19e siècle au début du xixème
siècle je pense que l'arabe du coup bah
oui on parle arabe en france depuis très
longtemps donc non mais moi je veux ça
ne sonne ça ne me choque pas du tout
mais en revanche en revanche bien là où
je vous rejoins c'est qu'on voit bien
quand même que dans ce débat il n'y a
pas beaucoup de sincérité quoi on voit
bien qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
d'arrières pensées qu'on veut on veut
construire des niches électorale on veut
on veut flatter un certain nombre de
gens dépensent et menton segment là on
se demande comment on se fait des parts
de marché comme ça je vous donne le
point de vue de nos internautes quand il
s'exprime par leur vote sur twitter
l'enseignement des langues régionales
risque-t-il d'entraîner une dérive
séparatistes et bien vous êtes une
majorité assez franches puisqu'il s'agit
des deux tiers 66% à considérer que non
lors nous dit on entend dans ce débat
que des gens qui vivent à paris et qui
ne connaissent aucune langue régionale
il faut laisser les régions vivre alors
vous disiez le schisme déjà que vous
préfériez les les langues régionales à à
l'anglais regardez c'est à quoi va
ressembler bientôt votre carte nationale
d'identité
pour l'instant c'est en test dans
certains départements mais ce document a
vocation à se généraliser alors si vous
êtes un peu loin de votre écran je vous
précise que les mentions classique nom
date de naissance lieu de naissance ne
sont pas seulement indiqué en français
mais aussi en anglais
bah on ne peut penser que c'est comme ça
ddd des douaniers par exemple des
policiers de pays étrangers pourront
plus facilement lire
est ce que ça vous choque ce genre
d'initiative j'aime beaucoup parce que
qu'est-ce que alors c'est propre à
l'union européenne je crois oui
absolument
alors
est ce que est ce que en suède au
danemark est-ce qu'on va écrire en
français
bah non mais en anglais vous le savez
bien c'est non mais c'est un problème ça
mais c'est bien sûr vous savez moi je je
connais bien ce sujet dans un autre
secteur mais qui est intéressant c'est
que dans le sport vous savez que le
français est langue olympique il ya
trois langues olympique le français
l'anglais est la langue du pays
d'accueil
pourquoi c'est nous qui avons ressuscité
l'esprit bien sûr et bien vous savez
c'est une bataille permanente de faire
respecter le français comme langue
olympique
moi je crois que la langue ça va au delà
de simplement d'une pratique c'est une
façon de penser c'est un modèle aussi
c'est un modèle culturel c'est une une
imbrication dans cet incident typhi à un
type de société la langue ça va c'est
bien plus que simplement communiquer et
le fait de vouloir absolument que
l'anglais est en plus un anglais qui est
quand même un anglais aujourd'hui un
anglais réseaux sociaux c'est à dire pas
très c'est pas l'anglais de shakespeare
le globish i ou ii ou d'edgar poe et en
anglais beaucoup plus aux primaires et
bien cet angle et là oui aujourd'hui il
induit une certaine une certaine
mondialisation une certaine façon de
penser guillaume bigot je vous taquine
mais si mes fiches sont à jour vous êtes
aussi directeur général d'une grande
école de commerce est vrai qui s'appelle
i pack business school
donc vous ne pouvez pas être contre ce
genre d'initiative vous me taquiner en
effet
en réalité on a recours à l'anglais
beaucoup parce que c'est une langue
vernaculaire des affaires et que c'est
une école de commerce
le terme business et contrairement aux
apparences d'origine arabe d'ailleurs
mais en fait et school ça vient de scola
sinon c'est la nôtre racines latines à
tous mais il y a essentiellement des
cours assurés par des anglophones de
naissance donc on porte attention au
fait que le sénat doit pas être un
mauvais anglais on n'a pas eu parce que
c'est vraiment d'un grotesque fini que
des enseignants disons français parlent
en anglais à des élèves français c'est
important la réalité dont beaucoup
beaucoup d'établissements aujourd'hui
rasad explications et enquête de l'oms
sur la carte d'identité vous êtes plutôt
pour plutôt contre écoutez moi je sais
que j'ai envie de dire c'est que j'ai
découvert à l'occasion de la pandémie et
du site du gouvernement sur le le coc
vide une nouvelle langue figurez vous
alors là j'ai débranché mon téléphone je
peux pas vous la montrer mais peut-être
qu'on va le retrouver auprès de j c'est
le français simplifiée serre que ce qui
nous menace et pas il ya l'anglais bien
sûr il y as peut-être des langues dites
séparatiste je n'ai rien contre
l'enseignement de l'arabe ce serait
formidable d'utiliser le fait qu'on ait
beaucoup d'apports de population de gens
qui ont la chance d'avoir des ancêtres
arabophones et et d'apprendre l'arabe et
l'arabe est une très belle langue c'est
une longue et intéressante en plus pour
notre diplomatie
ce serait formidable mais encore
faudrait-il qu'ils une cohésion
nationale forte
encore faudrait-il qui a une maîtrise du
français est forte et là évidemment le
français s'écroule la maîtrise du
français s'écroule
de sorte que le gouvernement était
obligé pour se faire comprendre
d'utiliser une nouvelle langue française
simplifiée voilà on en est là donc dans
ces conditions je pense que l'anglais
n'est pas une ouverture l'anglais
d'abord je rappelle que la grande
bretagne a quitté l'union européenne qui
a plus que 5 millions de franck
d'anglophones à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne et le deuxième argument c'est
que c'est un c'est un anglais vraiment
évidemment très très très appauvri est
que plus la construction européenne
avance et moins on apprend l'allemand -
on apprend l'italien mois on apprend les
autres langues européennes donc ça me
prouve bien que l'union européenne n'est
qu'un exercice et qu'elle est de ces
régions quel est l'intérêt de quoi quel
est l'intérêt d'avoir sur mon passeport
français d'avoir marqué name l'intérêt
je vous le disais que c'est que la carte
d'identité qui va l'alléger je voyage et
j'ai la chance de voyager dans le monde
entier le fait de présenter des papiers
écrans français n'a jamais posé le
moindre problème mer samedi
à tous les deux d'avoir été présent dans
cette émission merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver si tout va bien lundi prochain
pour une nouvelle édition de points de
vue très bon week-end
[Musique]